[Music]
Kylie Jenner taking a trip to the snow
to celebrate her pal Jody woods his
birthday that's her BFF Jordan sister
Kylie documented the excursion on
Instagram noting it was only a day long
getaway but that was just too long for
her to be away from daughter storming
Webster quote only 24 hours away from my
baby but not okay she posted this pic
reunited with stormy on Monday Kylie
kissing her little one who was all
bundled up in Burberry stormy will of
course turned 1 on February 1st and
Kylie has also said she started wrapping
her birthday gifts she also posted this
video a stormy and Jordan opening a
belated a Christmas gift et was with
Jordan just a month after Kylie gave
birth she had this to say about her
besties becoming a mom I also have to
ask you about your BFF miss Kylie Jenner
a new mom what's been the biggest change
that you've seen in her since she gave
birth to stormy I think that whenever
someone has a child no matter who it is
there's always growth and there's always
things to be learned so I think it's
just childbirth and just becoming a
parent it's a beautiful thing yeah she
said that when she told you you said
we're having a baby together
how have you been instrumental it's so
far I think no matter what your best
friend is it's important to be there for
them and be supportive and obviously you
want to help guide them in whatever
decision they make because everyone is
their own person they make their own
decision it's just your job to be there
as a friend Kylie has also been sparking
engagement rumors again but it's still
unclear if she and Travis Scott will be
walking down the aisle anytime soon ET
is with Kim last month she said this
love is Amir and your fellow beauty
model miss Kylie Jenner
she's Instagram pictures with her and
Travis Scott in a ring we're just asking
you are they they call each other
husband a wife or they married engaged
what it's the situation you know I'm
literally need to ask her that
gonna be my next question on our group
chat we were chatting on the way over
here and I think we just all think like
that's like you know what they call each
other but I have no idea I'm just like
you guys I'll find out I don't know if
I'll share the news with you guys but I
will I'll have to ask myself all right
guys how big do you think Kylie and
Travis are going to go for Stormies
first birthday we can always chat over
on Twitter and in the meantime be sure
to subscribe to all things
ét bye for now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]